Why did I have a river bond?
Why my boo?
Thank you so much.
Hello.
I'm the one getting spooked here.
Tadaima!
Oh, Kairi!
Wait a second.
I need to put on something.
Oh.
I got like a soap.
It so dries my hands.
I must revitalize the ectoplasm.
Got my ticket ready.
Can't wait to see your concert.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, it was next week.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, next week.
Oh, it's my 3D Jazz live show.
I'm very scared.
I'm scared!
Gosh, so soon.
I know, you're telling me!
There are streaming tickets available?
It's my shill time, shill era.
There are streaming tickets available!
Gingerface!
Happy birthday!
um what i want to do i asked i asked about this and they
said i could um do it uh it'll be on my schedule for next
week because i want you know there's gonna be a streaming
right for the show and the streaming is uh available for a
little like for a couple weeks i'm or so after the live show
and um i'd like to do like a little bit of a preview a sneak
peek if you will live stream of the of the bod um probably
will do that on well if all goes according to plan i want to
do it on a valentine's day so so so um yeah just like a
little like a here's what it's like for those who still need
a little bit of convincing for the streaming ticket booze
like you you're gonna kill it at the show i just know it
let's do some fishing yeah we got a fish we got a fish got
some really bad news just now so you streaming right now is
really helping
i'm sorry i hope everything's okay i hope everything's okay
Hi, Minto.
I'm old again.
Might have requested MGS-style birthday song, Deco-Less,
while I watch the snowfall in Ohio.
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
Happy birthday.
Wait.
How does it go again?
Why am I blanking out?
I'm having to remember so many things.
I can't even remember this.
MGS.
Birthday song.
Why can't I remember?
I have to look it up.
I can't even remember.
Okay, I remember.
My brain is... The brain fog is so real.
Yesterday, I was like, you know what?
I've been haunting pretty late hours recently, so I'm
gonna... I'm gonna hit the It was around 10 p.m., 11 p.m.,
and I was like, oh my gosh, I forgot to do this thing, and
so I was up until 3 a.m.
Just trying to fix, trying to finish it.
Ah!
My brain actually feels like it's gonna explode recently.
So I'm really sorry if I'm like extra brain foggy.
Anyways, Nicholas, it's your birthday.
Happy birthday, congratulations, happy birthday, we're
salutations, happy birthday, may your sky stay blue, happy
birthday to you, woo, happy birthday.
Yeah, and I have a double stream today, crazy, accidental
double stream, but that's okay, because I was really
enjoying this game.
So, yes, we will finish Ubigari today.
And we will catch those fish.
Catch those fish.
Catch those.
I was trying to figure out what I want to stream next week.
Because, you know, it's going to be a bit of a shorter week
since I will have the jazz show.
And I'm like, do I, since I'm, you know, I'm going to be
done with Alan Wake.
series part of me was like maybe Bioshock uncharted I don't
know it's my birthday too but only one to thank you and
thanks for everything this spot this spiral thank you happy
birthday happy birthday high tail yeah I could do some high
tail next week so Bioshock would be be so good right now
honestly i was not planning on having a second stream today
so i was going to play more of portal 2 and it's kind of all
i can think about i just want to play more portal 2 halo
thank you so much for the vibe get that thank you yeah maybe
bioshock would be fun to start i could probably finish it
before i go on my longer trip so that i can get it out of
the way i also have to plan for some like streams and games
that i can play while I'm away on my travel setup, so...
Maybe like a...
Like a...
Maybe I can bring my Switch.
Play some Switch games.
Since that won't take any computing...
Computing power.
Return of the Obradin?
I've played that one before.
Yes, yes.
Though...
I've played it!
But if you told me to do all of the puzzles once again, like
the connections of who goes where and what and how I
probably would not be able to tell you thank you thank you
nothing like spooky fishing to finish up a workday oh two
have you ever played half-life wait I can't tell if this is
a joke or not wait
When are you going to play MGSV?
Just curious, since I heard the birthday song.
Well, since it's such a long undertaking, I'm still figuring
out when I would have time to play it.
You know what I mean?
Because it would suck if I started it and then had to wait,
like, weeks in between each time I could play it.
I mean, I have played it before, so it's not like I'm
missing out.
But I do still want it on my channel.
I like to have games sometimes.
on my channel.
Maybe I've played them before.
Somewhere distant.
Other worldly places.
But I like to think of my own channel as kind of like my own
resume in a sense.
My resume, my catalog of things that I've done.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
You already played Halfway.
I did.
I did!
Yeah!
And two!
Yeah.
An archive.
Yes, my archive.
Yes, yes.
So sometimes I do like replaying things just so that I can
have them on my channel.
If that's the case, I'm gonna get fired.
Wait, what do you mean?
Why are you getting fired?
When are you playing Half-Life 3?
I'm marching to the...
Studios right now.
I...
Okay, I mentioned this in my Portal 2 playthrough.
But like...
Can you guys imagine a Valve-themed amusement park?
Like a Valve-themed park?
Oh my gosh.
Wouldn't it have been so awesome?
I've been thinking about it so much recently.
be so good except except um oh my gosh what is the place in
half-life that they're like we don't talk about this place
but we don't we don't want you we don't want to go there
yeah i had crab hats for 20 i know it would be i mean they
have honestly i feel like they have enough yeah ravenholm
ravenholm i feel like they have enough properties to like
make fun sections.
Like, you have, like, a Half-Life section, and then you have
the Team Fortress section, and then you have the Portal
section.
What else do that?
What else?
Left 4 Dead!
A lot of zombies.
Does that mean Super Mario 64 again?
Oh, no!
Oh, wait.
Maybe we don't want a Team Park.
Okay.
but i feel like i feel like you know we have obviously we
have like the mario world but i feel like video game
inspired amusement parks is such like an untapped market and
maybe maybe you could argue i would say even 10 years ago
especially 20 years ago even 10 years ago though sorry i
just realized the rate was like so long maybe you could
argue that like gaming was not like huge enough to to really
garner that kind of market but i feel like it's just i don't
know even
now i think that quote-unquote gamers are not taken very
seriously i think it's because so many people are silly
online i think gamers aren't taken very seriously so
probably it would take much more to be convincing Final
Fantasy could carry a theme park, I bet.
Right, like a square-themed theme park or something.
I don't know why I keep saying theme-themed.
But, seeing as enough time has passed since this was last
asked, I think I can ask this now.
Minto, may I have your permission to get another Aibu slash
Aibus pregnant?
What?
When?
Okay, why is it that it...
Why is it that the amount of time needs to be passed?
that why do you feel like you need to
like why is why is that the determining factor and not just
the content of the question itself and also is the other
party consenting to this all all I booze who are wanting...
Who are wanting...
To become...
Parents, raise your hand.
Um...
I had a weird stress headache earlier today.
I had a nap and it passed now.
Oh, good, good.
So I didn't feel like cooking at dinner time.
But now I'm getting hangry!
Could you recommend something yummy to order?
I had... I had a burger for lunch.
hamburger
there's like a have you guys heard that like sound that's
used in videos sometimes I think it's the guy that made the
let's go gambling sound and he made one that's just like
nothing ever is gonna make me happy in this world I can't be
happy and then it interrupts with hamburger that might be
mean hamburger
Rad X flip note It's funny because like I feel like it's so
millennial humor But sometimes it's fine to have like Gringy
fun Whimsy humor Hamburger It's so like Can I has
cheeseburger coated Maybe we are reverting back to The
golden texts Yeah
Somebody should buy an abandoned oil rig and make a mother
base theme park.
I have been saying this since I died.
I have been saying this forever.
I said this before I even played Metal Gear.
I just knew that I would love Metal Gear and I was like, you
know what, someone should do that.
And I'm like, why would I say that?
Who's possessing me?
Hi, hi, totally off topic.
Sorry, no, but I'm decoing your photo cards.
Who's your favorite Sanrio character?
Okay, I have two.
Recently, okay, I used to be like the biggest cinema.
Well, not, I don't want to say used to be.
I still love cinema roll.
But cinema roll was my number one for a super duper long
time.
And then, and then.
Hanamaru Obagehi, don't kill.
I love Hanamaru.
Hanamaru Obake is my favorite.
But it's kind of hard to find.
Well, there's lots of merch of them, but it's also like...
Obviously, Cinemarle is like way more popular.
We don't have hands to raise, Minky.
And honestly, I feel like Hanamaru makes more sense for me.
Because he's like, oh, listen.
So am I.
We are kindred spirits.
Stop, I'm the same way it's both Cinemarle and Hanamaru.
Yeah!
They're too good!
My only thing is I love with Cinemarol is like how much blue
like light blues.
You guys, actually light blue is my favorite color.
My name is Mint, but light blue is my favorite color.
And Cinemarol has so much good light blue.
Light blue coloring.
And the only thing about Hanemaru is he's always paired with
red.
So...
Scandal.
No!
I can't help how I died.
I can't help it.
Mid turquoise.
That's why you find that my mint coloring is a little more
on the bluish mint side than the greener mint side.
Ah, blue in my hair.
Yeah, little blue accents.
Oh, that's why.
Yeah.
I willed it.
Anyway, shall we continue the game?
Yes.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I forgot that it puts us here.
Okay, so just...
Wow, big boy.
Head to station.
We are headed to a new area.
Uh...
Uh, this away, this away, this away.
And, uh, yeah.
Um, you died in a mint-related accident.
I got, I got, I got, I worked in a double mint factory, and
it exploded, and I got, I got suffocated, probably.
Taking a dappy tool, catch contradiction later, but I wanted
to thank you for helping me push through comms by activating
my neurons with every two-nine.
I'd have a good stream, Vicky.
Good night, Tuner!
Tuner.
One second.
There we go.
Okie dokie.
So, but I don't think...
I think we need probably speed level four for this.
So we must fish.
We must cash money.
Aha.
I think the game got an update or something, and they still
didn't fix this.
There's also an achievement for finding every bottle.
So I think we need to go back here to then go to the next
place, probably.
Still got it, baby.
Still got it.
Give me my 500 yen.
Let's see.
boat seat is boat speed okay we can do that we can do that
we can do that we can do that we can do that we got this we
got this boat speed oh oh gosh he is so not okay there's
something about that guy ain't right something about that
guy ain't right oh wait i can fast pass what am i I just
travel.
Oh gosh, I really am Disney-brained, maybe.
Was that something green in the water?
It's curious.
I'm at half fuel, but we're just gonna chill around here.
We're gonna chill as art around here.
And we have our new bait machine.
Get baited.
But the fish here are fast.
Go out a little bit more.
Here we go.
Alright, come on fish.
Someone I can use as a bait.
Someone I can use and grind up and turn into a meatball.
How does that happen?
Mint the master baiter.
Don't say that.
Hello?
Are there any fish?
Did I rob the sea?
Look, it says there's one, two, three, four.
Where are you?
Is that one right there?
I think
I got baited.
I think I got baited.
Where's the fish?
No!
Wait, is this place...
Okay, wait, I keep thinking that I'm in the place with the
flying fish, but no, this place does not have the flying
fish.
It has the inky fish.
Oh!
down there.
No, come on!
If I did upgrades, I wonder if I'd be able to get them.
There's two of them there.
Might need bait to lure them out first.
Yeah, but there's no fish to bait.
There's no fish to turn into bait.
Everything is gone.
My seas are barren.
What's happening?
I think those are indication that there's these guys
underneath.
You see how it's like kind of fuzzy?
The economy!
My fish economy!
Bait!
I will have you yet, my sweet.
Are you gonna come back?
Ugh.
We gotta try again with this nasty guy.
They're still down there.
I see them.
Let me throw, like, a little...
Yes.
Yes!
Okay, now any other guys coming over?
You.
Alright, we can get the other one now.
It's good.
You put down one bait and you start getting a ton of guys.
It's great.
Plenty of fish in the sea, my ass.
Where is everyone?
I know, right?
Like, I feel like I'm crazy right now.
Got him.
Holy cow.
I forgot how big these guys are.
Wait, any others?
Any guys that I could get for bait?
Anybody?
Where are all the fish?
serious it was not this barren yesterday when i played
it was definitely not this barren yesterday when i played
i like to sell these guys pretty much immediately though
because at one i don't want them falling out and two oh i
think that's a guy Two, they take up so much space.
And let's, let's fuel up, too, before I forget.
Hoi!
Ha!
Shea!
Money, money, money, money, money.
How far can I go before I pass out?
I think it's really funny that there's no like uh no like
water breathing I guess because we were a fish do you think
that's why we there's no meter that says like hey you can
only breathe under the water for this amount of time because
we were a fish you think that is the case can I walk here or
am I going to pass out?
okay there's a guy there's a guy too I might just buy the
upgrade for my rod anyway not gonna lie
that and Chilla's game I think they just didn't care no no
they care they care surely there's some thought bomb I don't
mind it.
Surely.
It's so expensive, though.
I mean, we all are still fishes, but we no longer breathe
underwater.
I'm a fish?
Call me a fish.
Sorry.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
My bad.
You.
Get in there.
It's so horrible.
It's actually so disgusting.
There seem to be a handful of guys around this area.
We don't even need to go so far, I think.
Perhaps.
Maybe a little further.
Let's look for the bubbles.
Right?
How we saw those other guys with the bubbles.
I thought I saw somebody.
What?
At the top here?
Ow!
Oh, I did.
That's a...
Ew.
I feel like these guys are an invasive species, and so I'm
doing my part by getting rid of them, actually.
My ass would have stayed in the primordial soup if I knew
this was gonna...
There were gonna be days like this!
No!
Who hurt you?
Oh, it's this guy.
Oh, it's an Inky.
No!
Ha!
Oh, dang it!
I saw him.
Oh, it's another Inky.
Inky nastiness.
That's a scientific name.
Hoi!
I'm ready.
I'm prepped.
Yes!
I told you I was already in prepped.
I think we...
Oh, there's another...
Oh, dang it.
Ah!
Mid-me-to, fish slayer and sea captain of capitalism.
What is your wisdom of the day?
Fish are always in demand.
If you...
Don't like your job...
Oh, there's some guys over there.
Consider becoming a fisher.
Okay.
I saw them.
I saw their fins.
They taunted me.
Wait, did I just see one?
That's an Inky Nasty right there.
You might did not get it.
Inky Nasty.
Always be fishing.
You could quit and become a fisherman.
Eyes on the prize.
Yes.
Oh, there's a good amount of guys here.
Oh, nice, nice.
We'll be making big bucks here.
We'll make big bucks here.
That's what Minto's all about.
Fish.
Maybe I should change my profession.
From mid to fisherman mid.
I know there's a bunch of you here.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes, I need an Inky Nasty, please.
Mermaid.
Oops, oops.
So true.
Okay, I know the guys.
The other ones came from this direction.
There it is.
okay i'm gonna get these that last one there and then we'll
head over i just oh oh oh okay good i was gonna say i just
need a bait fish
all right wait for that to disappear chuck it in wait for
fish there he is
like sitting on piles and piles of cash right now my butt is
literally resting on them it's squishy and i don't like it
i'm uncomfortable i did see one over here oh there he is i
think
no you evade me once again my white whale i'm loaded i'm so
loaded I really am curious what will Don't fall out Don't
fall out now Why is my boat getting floated?
Oh, oh, oh, oh Okay, um I'm curious why What will be the
ending of this game?
Like where do we go from here?
Select all, sell all, baby Yeah!
Let's get our boat speed up What?
We even have enough to do the harpoon range.
I wonder how much of a range it is more, though.
Seems longer than a normal Chilizard game.
I know, right?
It's much longer, honestly.
Let's do it.
Da-da-da!
Hundred!
Three-ha- Well, if we get 10,000 yen here...
We're going to be making Buku Bucks in the next place,
surely.
I'm fast traveling.
To...
Where is it at again?
Okay, so we go to the school.
To the school.
Hello!
I'm taking your suspicious seashells once again.
She does sell seashells.
by the seashore and I'm the one who's selling them fish
padding not a bad thing I mean at least I enjoy the fishing
at least I enjoy fishing game otherwise it'd be like a slog
maybe hello wait okay we do have enough money for gas at
least and we are headed to this way three bells three bells
hi hi hello welcome back
are there enough chillos games by now to do a tierless
stream you know actually right before stream i was
organizing some of my games kind of just to because i was
like i said i was trying to i said earlier i was trying to
figure out what to play next week and i was organizing my
games I've already completed that, you know, like one-shot
games that I wouldn't go back to.
Or just story games that I've already completed, things like
that.
And through my list was so many Chilla's games.
Chilla, I think I've bought, I know I haven't bought all of
them, but I have bought so many of them.
I have played so many of these games now.
If I don't play one, it honestly just feels like, Like, I'm
not doing my job or something.
You know what I mean?
It's so silly.
And it's really fun also to see, like, how...
Oh, it's like, what's that sound?
I think it's the wind chimes.
It sounds so peaceful, though.
I mean, this is your job.
It is totally my job.
But what I meant is, like, uh...
Is, uh...
Hello?
Where's the second bell?
Oh, there it is.
I think I got it.
I got it.
What the heck is that?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, shoot.
I got lost.
Can I juke her?
Oh, my God.
We're gonna get eaten, guys.
We're gonna get eaten.
Okay, let's try that again.
But yeah, it is fun to see, like, how they've kind of
developed their games over time.
It's truly fun to see, in my opinion.
Resting with the fishies.
I'm gonna change this to this.
So we don't get lost again.
I also got caught on...
There's, like, no room for error in this.
It's crazy.
Okay, here we go.
There we go!
Here we go!
Maybe?
Oh yeah, we got that.
Easy.
Oh my god, oh my god, she's kept coming towards me!
I thought... I thought...
This is not half fuel, don't lie to me.
Holy cow, that was scary, huh?
She came through the gate.
I thought we were done for.
Because I just stopped.
I was like, okay, we're here.
La la la.
Hi.
I made it.
There's a train nearby.
Oh, is it that?
It's half fuel if you ignore the reserve.
Right.
Here comes the pain train.
What does that mean?
You know the girl on that train?
I can't really get close to her.
Half the stuff she says, I can't make sense of it.
I just hope she finds some peace and a way out.
Through my harpoon.
It doesn't help there are rumors.
There are rumors and Umibozu, a sea giant is nearby.
Gives me the creeps.
What about the fish here?
You confident with your harpoon?
this area is called pain train station is it really if you
are then use boost and go for it if not one trick is to get
close first then use bait but there's a fish that'll steal
your catch and eat it so yeah watch out for that one too
this is getting complicated things are getting complicated
so what's my task head to the station
So what kind of fishies we got in here?
Is that her crouched over?
Hold on.
We got the gold paint for our boat.
Oh, we got flying guys again.
Oh, look at them!
Wait, they're cute.
I probably missed one in that one building that I...
That had, like, the guys that would attack you.
Okay.
Dang.
My...
Return is like crazy now.
Have you noticed that?
I didn't upgrade that though.
I didn't...
I...
I upgraded the range.
But why is my return like so fast now?
Do you guys see that?
Yeah, it comes back instantly.
You usually have to pay for an upgrade for that.
huh I'm like still trying I'm like failing on all these guys
though anyway hello oh don't come any closer you're gonna
eat me too aren't you wait was it you after that next stop
my sister just vanished was it you who did it my sister used
to say all the time there aren't any decent people left in
the world so you're the same kind of good for nothing aren't
you don't come near me don't touch anything give me my
sister back if you're gonna lie and say you didn't eat it
then take me to the next station and prove it but you can't
move the train without the lever so i guess that's
impossible huh and i'm too scared to move if you're really
not some good for nothing then go find the lever we need to
get this train moving okay find the lever her name's reno
huh lever required Okay, I can't exit.
I'm not skinny enough for that door, huh?
These guys seem difficult.
Oh, the lava cronk.
Can I walk on this?
I wonder.
Oh, see, now it's taking...
Okay, okay.
That's so weird that it was like instant coming back to me.
Now it's taking its sweet time.
I wonder how far I can walk down this.
Is there a hot...
I can't...
Oh my gosh, wait.
They like swim right in front of me, though.
Which is kind of nice.
Except when they're so fast.
La la la la la la.
What are you?
Oh, it's a blobfish!
Okay, let's go back.
We got some bait.
Very good.
Wait.
Actually.
Who is the guy that's gonna try and eat our fish is my
question.
I'm scared about that.
Anybody?
Any takers?
I see like a really slow guy coming in from over there.
Hello?
Oh, it's just more blobfish.
You too.
I also hear that giant fish!
There he is!
Where are you giant fish?
Where'd you go?
Oh, you're over there.
Yes, I see you, I see you, I see you.
Oh, he's so scary though.
over here more
oh, I got eyes closed I need to find an open eye excuse me
let me try the other side uh uh
you guys see one that one oh yes it is oh oh oh oh
We got the second piece, the second tablet.
Oh my gosh.
How much?
Look at the lips on this sucker.
Oh, wait.
Where's the...
Wait, where did...
What?
This away!
How much is this guy gonna sell for, I wonder?
Use him as bait.
Save?
Oh.
we'll save once we sell him because well I should save
anyway because what I was gonna say is I don't think I'll
run out of fuel but just in case 500k you think so that
would be awesome that would be huge money I wonder who's the
guy that eats my bait, though.
You're guessing 300k.
I think more because I think 500k makes sense because we had
to go to three areas to get this guy.
It was no easy potatoes.
Hello, I have the big met.
I caught a giant angler fish.
Is that what he's?
Wait, can I see him from behind?
You actually got that thing.
Huh?
A second tablet shard.
Ah, well, keep it up, yeah?
Wait, I want to see a...
I just...
Whoa!
Oh, oh.
Oh, whoa!
Oh, wow!
Crazy!
Anyway, I'm taking the shortcut.
This is so...
Anyway, uh...
So?
75,000!
Guys.
Guys!
Not even 75,000.
750,000!
Holy cow!
What do we upgrade?
Okay, we upgrade our boat speed.
First of all, because we're We'll need to... Oh, wait.
There's gonna be another one?
The price went up again.
We upgrade our fuel capacity.
We upgrade our harpoon stuff.
I could do the rest of the harpoon things.
It says 5 out of 5 because I think you have to unlock the
next one at the next area.
Then it will say it only says like 3 out of five because i
haven't been keeping up with like paying for all of them
sonar speed it's cheap that's true i do use it the boost i
wonder if we'll need it for later like a boss fight or
something you know i haven't been i you can't use it in the
areas with the with the giant monster that's trying to eat
you so i haven't been like worrying about it but i'm
wondering a boss fight that you'll need it.
Bait range is king as well?
Okay, we'll try that.
NPCs do keep mentioning boost.
You're right.
I'll do that instead of my harpoon.
Oh, the boost speed!
We completely bought all of those upgrades.
Nice!
I'll even do the bait range.
Okay.
Yeah, this level did say, this did say, like, boost and...
Boost and...
Bait and stuff for this one.
Wow, whoa!
We did so many upgrades!
Let's go!
Oh, look at it!
Ew.
Wait, that's a human.
And a fish.
Ew.
Let's save.
And then let's go get some...
Oh, wait.
Nope.
Let's get some fuel.
All right.
All right, all right.
And we're trying to find a lever.
What the heck is this guy?
Oh.
Oh, he's worth a good amount, though.
I'm wondering, I guess these are the guys that might try to
eat my
if I, like, do the bait.
But hey, I think I'm willing to use Oh,
there's another one.
Now I want to know how much the flying guys are.
I imagine maybe 300,000.
That's my guess.
That is my guess.
All right.
I'm going to throw it out over here.
Oh!
Ew!
How much was it?
300!
Yes, uh, yes.
Oh, I keep saying 300.
Sorry, my brain in numbers.
But yes, I was right what I was thinking.
Yes!
Everybody still in?
Oh!
Okay, clearly...
No!
Not everybody can stay in the boat.
I don't know where I dropped him.
No!
You need a bigger boat.
I wish we could have a boat capacity.
Or at least if I could put them in like a dang tro- like a
chest or something.
Oh, don't!
Wasted.
Yeah, 325 if you ignore.
I'm gonna use these guys.
I know they're worth a lot.
But I'm gonna start using them as bait.
They're very easy to get.
And I don't want them eating.
My...
My more expensive guys.
because they take up so much space in here.
Wait, did I just lose?
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
Let's drive a little over here.
Alright, alright.
And I see no sharks.
So I'm gonna throw.
See if anyone comes up.
Actually, I kind of want to see him, like, eat one, though,
you know?
Hey, hey!
Oh!
saw him eat one.
What the hell?
You bastard!
I got no money at all.
Because of him.
Over here seems like a lot.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is good.
Everybody?
Wait, did I just...
Oh!
Ah!
No!
Oh!
here they come they come
oh they're huge they're really big okay I feel like I got
the bait thing but it does not okay I guess that feels a
little further away here he comes here he comes nice they do
look happy don't they maybe being a fish is bliss fish is
bliss.
Let me take off my...
Let me go.
Oh, they're so slippery.
Even docking is scary.
I wonder where my other one went if maybe it despawned.
Holy!
Let's go!
Maybe range means how many fish it attracts.
Oh, that's probably it.
You're probably right.
Rather than my throw range, it's probably the range at
which...
Oh, you're probably right!
That makes way more sense.
Hmm.
Okay.
We got some money.
for now let's uh let's drive into whatever this place is
first the lit up one the coin laundry
construction zone well perfect parking right here oh
my god are you wait are you naked i can't tell put fish i'm
washing the fish
hello I don't know I in the germaphobe I just feel dirty
it's been bothering me ever since I turned my body and my
mind feels sticky like I'm not clean no matter how much I
wash I start sweating right away it makes me hate myself oh
no ah man oh didn't you read the terms of becoming a human
ah no he's wearing too thank goodness germaphobe no back
when i was in the water i was never like this people say
humans are filthy and yeah now i get it fish have turned two
haven't they so they must be dirty too i'm hungry and i want
to eat but i want to eat clean fish a fish at the
construction site that turns invisible in the dark one-eyed
ghost those little guys as It's like they're avoiding the
light because they're bothered by how dirty they are.
Could you bring me three of them so I can wash them?
Looks like you'll need a light to find that fish.
Eating untainted fish with an untainted body.
Oh, how wonderful that sounds.
Find the light.
What the heck does this mean?
Okay, we have two side quests.
We're finding the light.
and finding the lever.
I am untainted.
I untainted body.
Wait, so what's going on in here?
Am I going to be scared?
Is it going to be dark?
It doesn't look that dark in here.
Wait, what's this over here?
This isn't the train that I was just at, is it?
This is different?
I think?
Yeah.
Oh.
What is that?
Clothes?
Hmm.
What is there?
I like how much...
Oh.
What's going on down here?
Am I going to turn around?
Wait!
It's donkey!
Am I going to turn around and get jump scared?
Oh.
Wait, what is...
Oh, there's another one.
So far, there hasn't really been any jump scares, have
there?
Not really, at least.
We found Oki.
Okay, back to the construction site.
Just weirdness.
Yeah, just uncomfy, right?
Just a little uncomfy so far.
Which I'm okay with.
Oh, oops.
That's fine.
Actually, I should have done that just to get back to my
Ship faster.
Wait, so they're in here?
Hello?
I need to find the light
I can't climb this as things Is it something to do with this
sky?
I'm gonna see if there's any sort of ladder that I can climb
I'm not seeing anything.
Let's try the Ferris wheel?
Holy, we are boosting!
Oh my god!
When I use the boost, we go crazy!
Crazy mode.
I thought I saw something.
Hold to fuel and rotate the Ferris wheel.
I'm so small.
Oh, I got every spray can!
Let's go.
Uh-oh, I'm using my own fuel for this.
Oh, okay.
Do I have to check?
Like, it's odd.
Oh, there's one up there that's a different color.
You see it?
Okay.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Oh my god, it's draining so much of my fuel!
We got it.
Yay!
Wait.
Oh, light installed.
Shop updated.
Oh, the shop updates even!
Oh, look at that!
Oh my, oh, my eyes.
Oh, oh, oh, my cursor is now like the light!
Oh, interesting.
I can see so well now, though.
Oh, cool.
Extra, extra meat.
You definitely want to refuel and sell things.
So that I can, uh...
Go find some three-eyed fishies.
Alan Wake.
No!
Uh, shop.
Sell.
And then what do we have for the light?
Oh.
You saw that, though.
Is it the shop upgraded?
Or updated?
Okay.
Never mind.
Lies.
I don't know how I feel about the light, I'll be honest.
I can't see anything!
It's so bright!
I'm gonna... well, actually...
I was gonna get some of those fishies.
But...
We could still do that.
I'll just go, like, get one and sell it.
You know?
Hoi!
Come on in!
Oh, oh, oh!
Yay!
Maybe we can get a second one.
That'd be awesome.
Oh, lucky!
Oh, lucky.
Oh, we barely just missed this guy.
I'll take him, too.
Great snipe.
Yeah, we got so lucky.
I'll take you, too.
Oh, my gosh.
I have to really watch my speed now.
My boat is too fast and these fish are too slippery.
Please!
Can you buy my fish from down here?
Thank you.
We can even...
Oh my gosh, we're like making so much money now.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Alright.
Let's...
I'm gonna save real quick.
Yes.
buff go fast debuff gotta go fast no option only fast only
fast nothing else fast only let's go in here oh never mind
what was that did you guys hear that it was like a kind of
kind of noise i think i have to go and like, they're this
way.
Hello!
I can't see anything.
It's so dark.
This is where I'm supposed to find these fish, right?
Do you guys hear the...
Oh!
I think I saw one.
It's so quiet.
You heard it, right?
Oh, okay, good.
It wasn't footsteps.
It was like a...
It was like a very, like a...
I don't know how else to describe it.
There, there, right there.
Oh, there's one!
I think they're the ones...
It looks like Mike Wasowski.
Oh, they're like, I think they're hissing from the light.
Yeah, they're hissing from the light, I think.
Oh, they're worth it.
Uh-oh.
Uh, one second.
My camera froze for a second.
Yeah, it's going...
They're worth a good amount, though.
Hmm.
Hello.
I know you were here.
Oh.
Where is he?
Where are you?
I hear you hissing.
Maybe I went to the other side.
Maybe.
I don't know how to get in over here, though.
I don't know if I can.
Oh, I think all the way on that end.
But that's okay.
We'll try from here.
Did I just see something swim past?
Like, over there?
Ah!
Oh!
Where do you go?
Got him.
Yeah, they're invisible till you shine the light on them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just couldn't hear them.
They kind of give like an audio cue, which is nice.
Oh, they're here and here too!
Ooh!
They're out here also.
Okay, we just needed three of them, no?
I'm chugging away.
Okay.
Number one.
Into the dryer.
Number two.
You think they're kind of cute?
Do they look like me?
Maybe if they had big old blue eyes.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Wait for the laundry to finish.
You still have all your panties on, right?
What is happening here?
Hello?
Oh, oops, my bad.
Is that it?
What am I supposed to do?
Is there...
Oh, maybe the lever is in here?
Okay.
I think he died.
It's so loud, I just want to get out of here.
Okay.
I think he's dead.
Boopsy, boopsy.
Never got...
Never got his fish.
Maybe he...
What a way to go.
It's kind of crazy.
I'm here to help you.
Bye, Bolt!
Goodbye, by...
Goodbye, by Bolt!
Uh-oh.
Wait, my Bolt.
Are you okay?
You don't want to talk?
That's wrong, right now.
Wow!
We're on the train!
This guy's...
Oh, whoa.
What's happening?
Wait, what's going on?
Wait, why is it...
Why is it scary?
Wait, that's not good.
Uh-oh.
What's happening?
Are you okay?
Wait, why are we...
Are we okay?
What's happening?
I see the station.
We should be fine.
Is there something following us?
Oh, no.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
What?
Ouch.
Oh my gosh.
I'm working on it.
Are we good?
Oh.
Oh, everything's fine.
Everything's A.
Okay.
Who are we waiting to pass?
We are the train.
Why were we waiting for another train to pass?
I didn't see one.
Yeah, minor setback.
Is it going to happen again?
I'm concerned that the fact that we're not already at the
station means it's going to happen twice.
I was correcting my assumption.
Oh, my...
Oh, shoot.
Let me follow you!
He was freaky!
Oh, I think we're here!
I think we're here!
The next stop is...
Oh, wait, we just went in a big old circle.
Is that your sister?
Uh-oh.
I have bad news for you.
The Eldritch Tentacle Horror from the Deep.
Think trains are neat.
Go to play with one that is operational.
It freaking stabs you.
Ouch.
Like how she has her headphones on, unbothered.
Is that your sister or...
You know, I've been thinking about my sister this whole
time.
Her last conversation, it was full of nothing but despair.
She said, I don't want to disappear.
I want to go back to the sea.
And I couldn't bring myself to listen.
And when I watched her while she was talking, it seems like
all of the humans don't like being fish and all the fish
don't like being humans.
I think that maybe that's what we're trying to do is bring
things back to the natural order.
When I watched her while she was talking, she was talking.
I'm the one who ate my sister!
The real good for nothing was me.
I was so hungry, I didn't know what else to do!
She was so important to me, and still, maybe I've been
running away this whole time.
I'm awful.
Oh, thank you so much for the breather!
Hello, readers!
Cannibalism happened again.
Don't worry, she's not a human, she's a fish.
But when I look at you, I feel like someone can...
Someone like me can take a step forward for her sake too.
In this hopeless world, I can finally see a glimpse of life.
Remak, thank you!
I'll leave something on the train for you.
Just a small thank you.
Thank you.
This is where you ate her.
Yikes.
Another bell, another bell!
Wait, can I stop at my... Wait a second, I just realized.
Does it stop at my... Oh, okay, yeah, it's gonna stop over
there.
Phil, thank you!
Believe it or not, 117XX, same as yesterday for cannibalism.
Freaky!
No way!
We're on a cannibalism schedule, baby.
Cannibalism always comes on time.
Three bells again.
Okay, I have trouble with getting on the rocks.
Can I have a minto on the rocks?
Melly, welcome back.
Thank you.
I brought back three bells.
You brought the bell with you.
I'll attach it.
Nathan, thank you so much for the gift.
This is the last bell to be installed.
Good work.
Keep it up, my friend.
The last bell!
We did it!
Okay, though.
Wait, though.
Look at this.
It looks like so expansive.
We didn't even reach the edge of the...
of the area.
It's kind of fun.
If we go out there and we see Umibozu, I wonder.
Should we experiment?
Are you safe?
We're just gonna explore right quick.
With the intention of not coming back.
Because I might run out of...
I feel like I'll run out of...
What's it called anyway?
Um, gas.
High speeds.
I'm like, just, I'm just gonna follow the, you know.
There's that lighthouse!
We couldn't make it to there before.
Wait.
That makes no sense.
How are we able to see it from here?
Oh, look, there's the edge.
because i saw it didn't i see it went like all the way
somewhere else oh hmm couple thank you
i feel like we can make it there maybe
maybe i mean i already did say we were gonna go this way
with the intention of not making it back but paying train
station all aboard maybe we i see something like over there
that's going crazy look at this look at this there's another
boat it's a ghost what wait what is this wait is that a is
that a tuna driving this boat Wait, there's a fish driving
that boat.
Wait.
I'm trying to get him to crash into me.
Can I talk to you?
Ah!
There has to be something with this guy.
Hello?
Oh, yeah, let's harpoon him.
Let's harpoon him.
I'm, like, following him.
I wanted to talk to him, not harpoon him, but...
You leave me...
Oh!
You leave me with no choice, Tira.
Oh, my gosh.
I feel like I'm in a dogfight right now.
Uh-oh.
Oh, my heal!
Oh, he's fast.
Oh, my God!
Oh!
I had him a couple times.
I feel like I...
I got him!
He was crying!
I got an achievement for it.
Okay, let's go back home.
That's fun.
Wait, where am I?
Oh.
Oh geez.
Are we gonna make it back home?
We could try.
I'm halfway.
Take his boat.
Actually, I'm going to hold you so that I don't lose...
Wait, how much are you?
Yeah, I'm going to hold on to you.
200k!
Money, baby, money, money, money, baby, money, money, money.
I'm seeing that boosting does not make the fuel go down
anymore.
Like, any faster, you know?
Wow, I feel like we didn't go out that far at all.
Maybe the train was really slow.
Wait, where is he?
Oh.
He's still on my boat, right?
Does that count?
Hello?
Tuna with legs!
Yippee!
Nice.
Maybe we do upgrade my harpoon.
There was another talk option.
Oh, is there?
No.
There wasn't.
I think it was just about the fish here.
Which is normal.
Yay!
We got that fish.
We got it.
let's see all right um maybe get the fuel option
i mean i could okay i do want to make my harpoon better
though i think harpoon is more important oh gosh it's gonna
be another upgrade that's crazy
feels like the harpoon is being used a lot more during
fights i agree that's why like having the speed and the
range and everything or the reel coming back faster would be
good um okay so now let's fast travel to the first island i
want to change my oh i like the black is this one new no
that one's not new oh my goodness the gold is Wow.
Is this one new?
Full wide.
It looks newish.
Oh!
That's interesting.
It's cute.
I don't know for a boat.
This one looks like a real boat now, doesn't it?
It's a knit boat.
Alrighty!
Let's head to that last area.
Where's my harpoon?
Wait.
It's saying throw slash drop.
Wait a second.
Uh, I'm gonna reset.
Wait.
You guys see that though, right?
It's saying throw slash drop, like right above my head.
And I think maybe the tuna glitched out.
I don't have my harpoon anymore.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
I don't have my harpoon anymore.
Look how many we've gotten though.
We see Q.
Yeah, the Q is the throw slash drop.
Uh-oh.
I just saved because I didn't realize.
Let me try loading.
I think...
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
We're heading to the city.
Okay.
Let's go!
This one over here.
Just normal Chilla Jank.
Yeah, you get used to it.
Yeah.
Alright, let's hope we don't die here.
Alright, I see the first... Wait.
I just realized...
Level 5, is that what that says?
We are level 5.
Okay.
mark that as our objective.
Okay, let's go!
Why is it in the sky?
Okay, we're close.
I think we're good.
Easy peasy.
Yeah, oh, keep going.
Omnis city front.
Oh, whoops.
I guess I could have saved after going to the gas station,
but whatever.
Woo-hoo!
Yahoo!
I'm here.
Hi, I made it.
Nice city.
We got going on here.
It's like mixed between Tokyo Tower Skytree.
About the city ahead.
You're thinking of going to that city, huh?
Hmm.
Yeah, I see.
That place is where the dangerous ones gather.
Oh, no!
We go there too, but let's just say things are getting out
of hand fast.
Customers are getting pickier, too.
Becoming real gourmet.
They're getting more and more insatiable by the day.
And some of us vanishing all of a sudden.
It's not just once or twice either.
The city is full of unknowns.
I wouldn't recommend going in.
Maybe, just maybe you could be the one to turn this all
around.
Yes, he's selling a shotgun.
Yeah, Mr. Rem, I need some, like, you know.
This city is full of unknowns.
What does that mean?
We don't even have an objective.
I don't want unknowns.
Well, who are you?
Hello.
I'm boarding the ship.
Is this your first time in the city?
The city has a person in each district looking for a
specific fish.
There are four of them in total, but...
Their requests are pretty tough.
But if you can fulfill the request, it sounds like you'll
get something in return.
But maybe you could handle it.
I marked them on your map, so if you want, please go check
them out.
Oh, before you do... before that, do you see the tower right
over there?
That's the symbol of the city.
You might want to visit the tower first.
That doesn't sound like a...
Like a suggestion.
sounded like a, you should visit the tower first.
Whoa.
Oh, this place is huge.
I wonder what kind of game they're going to make next after
this.
I'm sorry, a lighting!
No, what?
What the hell is that?
Is that, no way, is that a lizard?
Lizards persist?
Oh, wow, there's so many people.
Chilla in space?
Yeah, we're gonna get to space, eventually.
Ah, to you.
So you really are not like the others in this world.
Oh, it's the girl from the shrine!
Why did... How did you... Why did...
I'm doing everything I can, but this world just isn't
normal.
Things never go as planned.
What about you?
Yeah, you really are different from the others around here.
Why am I here, you ask?
Yeah, that's literally what I said.
Moon taunted.
Moving time, dude.
Well, there's a vicious shark in this city, and I saw him
holding the third tablet shard.
So I found that maybe with a mortar?
Oh my god, we could take down the shark.
But it seems you'll need four parts to complete the weapon.
Go down to go, yo.
So you can find all four...
Oh, so could you find all four parts of the weapon for me?
Oh, okay.
Awesome.
That's not a lizard.
It looks like a lizard.
Doesn't look like a shark.
I'll tell you that.
Oh, oops.
I'm really hoping that the requests aren't going to be
like...
Okay, I need this fish from this area.
And I need you to go get this fish from this area, you know?
And, like, it's a whole huge, terrible fetch quest.
Alright, let's go to this guy first.
Um...
But I have a feeling, I have an inkling that it's going to
be that way.
Wait, this is the first guy that we just spoke to.
Do you need something more?
Probably safe to assume so.
Probably.
I wonder if I can fast travel with fish.
Wait, he's gone.
Is he up here?
On top?
How do I get up?
How do I get up there?
Hello?
How do I enter your...
refined establishment.
Literally nobody up here!
Okay, never mind.
Whatever happened to the fish in the laundromat?
That's a great question.
Alright, let's go to this guy first then, I suppose.
I am gonna save real quick, though.
Alright.
Drive.
This guy here.
Hello, hello, hello!
Is that a nice little park?
She sells seashells by the seashore.
Place fish.
Hello!
Pee!
Hurry the hell up!
Get to work!
I need an orfish!
Oh, we have not gotten orfish yet, so...
If you keep the boat moving and be looking around, it won't
come at you.
Once you find it on the sonar, don't look towards it.
Let it get close.
Once it's close enough, stab its face.
It's fast as hell, but it won't take the bait.
Just a sicko that attacks people.
Okay.
A sicko, a real sicko.
I don't think orfish are aggressive, are they?
Watch the sonar carefully.
Let it get close.
Close enough that it pokes its head out of the water.
But don't let it get too close.
or it'll bite your ass.
And in that case, you guessed it, your ass is gone.
No, that's all I have.
So don't die.
Bring me the orfish.
Okay, okay.
It seems it's stuff in this area then.
At least for now, because we have not caught an orfish
before.
So that's good.
That's good to know.
How do I know what the orfish is like on the radar, though?
Is my question.
Maybe we should get the updated radar that's faster, right?
Right?
Maternity.
I wonder if I can go into these places.
Like the red area?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh!
My ass is grass!
We found him?
He's gone?
Okay, hold on.
He went this way for sure.
I might have to upgrade my sonar for this.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'm not looking.
He's gone again.
No, he's there.
I'm not looking at you.
He's over there.
Oh, shoot!
What?
That did so little damage.
No way!
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Getting it in the face really does help.
I couldn't tell what it looked like, though.
That's kind of sad.
I want to see what it looks like.
It looks like it has a lady head.
Oh!
Alright, alright.
All right, all right.
This isn't so bad.
Oh, we got her!
Okay.
Nice.
Time for a boss fight.
That was easy.
I want to see it, though.
I really was trying to get my ass.
Took you long enough.
Thank you.
I got...
Oh, I got the bullet.
Let's go.
Yeah, it was an orfish, though, obviously.
Iku nagai from Toho Project.
I see it with the ribbons.
Yeah, bullet.
Big bullet.
Alright.
is taken care of.
Let's go to this one next.
Can I sneak through here?
Yes.
Why so?
Right over here.
I want to see the shark from up here.
Oh, you can see him!
What is he doing up there?
Oh.
Raiden?
Oh my gosh, you guys!
Metal Gear Solid!
Rising!
I mean, not this, oh wait, Metal Gear Rising!
Ryden is here in the...
Wow!
Look at the dumpy on this guy.
Konkura!
I'm Kurana!
So you're the new guy.
I want you to gather some swordfish here now.
Swordfish are super fast.
Use boost to chase them down.
That's your best bet.
When it tries to escape, it usually just circles around the
area, so it shouldn't be too hard.
The moment you get close, it'll run away quick.
It'll test your harpooning skill for sure.
Wait, how many do I need?
Five!
Five of them!
Okay.
What do they look like?
Five of them.
I don't see anything in like the...
Wow!
I wonder how close we can get.
Wait, let me save.
I don't know why I save when I know it's gonna like take us
back to wherever it does, but you know what I mean.
The main island.
Wow!
It looks so stupid.
Yeah, that is a goblin shark now, isn't it?
I don't see any fish on the sonar.
at all maybe over here i just like how he's like up top is
that them oh that's definitely them okay
it's really hard to shoot wow see my i aim one way and my
thing goes another i think i have to like be next to them
This is tough.
Why does it go sideways like that?
You see it?
Ah!
I got
gold.
He's got...
That's...
He's got some...
He's got a long man.
Okay.
I might need to fill up for this one.
For this task.
Hey!
I mean, I might need to go fill up first.
Oh yeah, my fuel is really low.
Okay, let's go do that first.
It's over there.
Low fuel!
Oh no, no, no!
We're okay, we'll make it.
I wish I had some cash though to...
I mean, I have a little bit of surplus, but...
Okay.
Let's go get our dino!
I feel like that swordfish is based on someone, but I don't
know who.
Now who could it be based on?
Are you projecting?
Right in here.
Wait, did they just go this way?
I lost him.
What the heck?
Why did my harpoon go all the way that way?
Ugh.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, uh, uh, uh.
Ugh, I was hoping.
It's easier in here, I think.
Ha!
What?
I've already had fuel!
No, please!
This is so hard!
I can't shoot straight!
Please!
Ah, I got one!
Okay, we got one.
Yay!
This one's tough.
What happened to your eagle eyes?
I'm a ghost!
What are you talking about?
I've never been an eagle ever before in my afterlife.
Alright, number two.
Save.
Oh, I didn't mean to make a new one, but whatever.
Um, I feel like I need to go get some feed.
for money.
I can't keep fueling up like this, you know?
Let's, before, okay, let's try a different guy.
Let's just go check out someone else and see what they want,
you know?
We'll come back to that one.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, does that just say Village Vanguard?
Oops.
Oh.
It does!
Oh my Gosh, a village vanguard!
What the heck?
It's not even like a parody.
It's just straight up village vanguard.
I love this store.
It's like...
It's the exciting bookstore.
A lot of idol lives happen here.
You became an eagle briefly, and then you pulled a Huey
acrylic suit.
Shut up.
Yeah, it's a place in Japan.
a lot of idols perform here because they have like well the
one in shibuya has a stage so if you go um you might be able
to catch a show but it's uh usually you have to like buy the
single for the idols there they do it to like promote a new
album or single or something um but it's a very cool store
in general they have a lot of interesting stuff wow i didn't
that's so crazy to just have
his lips oh my gosh i go in zozo town like i've been
recently looking for a like a bag that is sold out but i've
been checking zozo town like every day to see if someone
puts it up in the use category what the heck why are these
like brands straight up straight up using their names those
look like thingies in the water hello oh cool guy you i
don't recognize you so you're to do it or not oh go catch
some piranhas for me you let that thing spy you it won't
stop it'll tear into you until there's nothing left if you
want one piece of advice use bait they're always starving
don't get clever don't waste my time just put the fish in do
that and i won't have to feed you to them instead how many
do you need two two two twenty Hello!
It's not the guys that are glowing, is it?
Are those the bait?
Oh, oh, wow.
It's a jellyfish.
Uh...
I don't know where I'd see one, but let's just...
Whoop!
Piranha!
I'm scared of this one.
How much are they worth?
I don't know.
Okay.
How much are the jellies worth?
True, I should grab a couple, right?
And sell them?
They're worth?
Oh, okay.
$1,000.
$1,000, $1,000.
$10,000.
Yeah, I'll take these.
I'll take these and we'll go get some gas.
I'm afraid of getting spotted by a piranha now, though.
Free money?
Yeah, easy money, rather.
Alright.
Let's head back to...
Maybe since I got two of the...
Swordfish, I just try and do that one.
Oh my gosh, wait, I'm scared.
I think we'll make it.
I think so.
It ain't great though.
I think we'll make it.
Everybody survived?
What do you got here?
Oh, wait, can I have that?
Can I have that?
Ew.
Hi, Mito.
Hello!
Okay.
You know, maybe I have more money than I thought I did.
But you know what?
It's good.
Just in case.
You know what?
Actually, if we want upgrades and stuff too.
Upgrade.
Maybe we do the bait range for the piranha.
And...
Harpoon gun!
Wait, we really can get a Harpoon gun!
Oh!
Upgrade Harpoon into Harpoon Garden.
Whoa!
Oh, I just spent...
We could get that.
The Poon Garden.
Yes.
I'm just...
I'm sorry, this boat speed goes up to seven now.
What the heck?
I know there probably has to be a achievement for getting
all of the upgrades and such but let's go back to this guy
we will do the swordfish we will do the swordfish and then
i'll do the piranha don't call it that what someone else did
in chat what is it bad what's it mean the
gun would make swordfish easier i think so too
Oh my god.
I'm so not good at this.
Where are you guys going?
This way?
I'm just following him real quick.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ha!
Nice!
Oh, my bad.
My bad.
Excellent shot.
Thank you.
I thought so too.
Who needs a gun?
Hopefully I can get one more before they disappear on me!
They're all like together here.
Oh, oh, there they are.
Is getting hit?
Oh, getting hit does lower my fuel.
Oh, I just noticed.
Oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
My fuel!
wait i didn't know about that oh god wait are we gonna make
it oh don't hit me don't hit me don't hit me oh my god i go
get more fuel wait this sucks
oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god it's right over here
here we're okay i think we'll make it yeah we made it we
made it
oh okay well that's good to know i was wondering i was like
dang my fuel is like going down crazy it's because they're
literally attacking it i wonder if me running into the walls
also also brings it down a little bit
what is this for oh it's for the convenience store movie do
you guys know that they were making that what's up with like
indie Japanese games getting movie adaptations recently
first we had well not first but recently we had exit 8 and
now we have
chill is all Huh!
There, shot!
Ow.
Oh, I'm so not good at this part!
Yeah!
No!
Ah, yeah!
Oh, I got him!
Okay.
Another guy down.
Yeah, I only had one.
I only had one.
Alright, just one more.
get okay I hope the piranhas are not we have wait how many
parts do we need to for like this thing, you know?
How many people are there?
Hello?
Wow!
Yes!
Okay.
Yippee!
That was easy.
Thank you, guys.
Alright.
Hello.
At last, their blood is all I need.
I'll enjoy this.
the shrine like next to this whatever this oh two out of
four okay you guys are right good job also look there was an
update already it shows like this is the old version of the
game now we're on the new version of the game let's go put
these on the tower
Tiny shrines, so cute.
He really is just, like, riding.
He's riding.
Oh, oh, oh, there's a shell here.
I would have missed it.
Wait.
Oh, oh, they're already attached.
How convenient is that?
Am I doing good?
I'm doing everything I can.
B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B.
Let's go, yo.
Okay.
Let's go.
Piranha.
I'm half-fuel.
Let's go try the Piranha first.
Maybe we can see what happens.
I am cannibal.
Cannibal, cannibal, cannibal.
Uncheck.
Oh, there's this guy right here.
He's pretty close.
Let's check him out first.
Cannibal, cannibal, cannibal!
Can I hop this fence?
Hoi!
Hi, Doru!
Wait, her outfit's so cute!
What do you, okay, zero out of five.
What do you need?
Kon Yuri.
I'm Yulia.
You'll help me, right?
Nice.
Looking forward to it.
These mermaids are really good for my odd eyes.
I want you to catch five and bring them here.
They're transparent unless they're hit by light.
They're also violent.
One climbs onto your boat.
When you don't take it down in time, it'll kill you.
You can't catch it while it's stuck on the boat, so grab it
before it gets on.
Oh, shoot.
I just got here and you're thinking about cannibals.
Do we need to hide another body?
Best of luck, but don't worry.
If you die, I'll remember your face.
Okay.
So I can't let it get on my boat, or else I die.
And I can't see them unless I have a really bright light.
Like this.
They probably make a sound, probably.
I'm scared.
What if they gang up on me?
Oh, oh.
Uh.
The sonar says.
Did I get it?
Wait.
Ah!
I'm still trying to...
Wait!
I'm so confused!
How am I not getting them?
How am I not reeling them in?
I'm so confused.
It is kind of scary though.
Is it because they're touching my boat?
Oh, that's so lame.
Ew, that's so lame.
So I have to get them, like, far away.
Oh my god.
I can't even reach it.
Wait, this is bad.
Okay, here we go.
And then...
Ah!
Oh!
Uh-oh, wait, uh-oh, wait, uh-oh, wait, uh-oh, let's leave.
Did you see how much these guys are worth?
Nice.
Face down, so...
Uh...
With respect.
So respectful.
That's the word I was looking for.
I'm trying to figure out if I want to keep going or if I...
Like, is that one right there?
Oh, that's a jellyfish.
Just kidding.
Sheila saw the anglerfish from Outer Wilds and said, What if
they were hot?
Yeah, exactly.
Okay.
Oh, there's a couple.
This is where it's good to have the fast...
speed for the...
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
Okay.
Oh, we need to go.
We need to go now.
There was another one coming at me.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
Yeah, the real speed is like saving my booty for real.
Ha!
Get up for real!
They're so freaky.
They're like sardines!
Ugh.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, they're so close.
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Heya!
Nice.
And that man should be just one more?
I see...
No!
How did you get there so fast?
I see one on my radar.
Oh, they're coming for me.
They're coming for me.
Scary.
It is pretty freaky.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh my gosh, how?
Back it up.
Maybe I can get it in time.
Yay!
Nice.
Alright.
This one was probably...
Well, actually, I think the first one was the easiest.
With the orfish.
This one wasn't bad, though.
It was just a little freaky.
So he managed to stay alive.
I can feel my eyes.
settling down already.
What does that mean?
Okay!
I feel like, though, we should grab some mermaids.
For money.
No?
Maybe we should grab some mermaids for money.
I should go fuel up, though, before we do the piranhas.
I don't even know what the piranha challenge is like, so it
could be really brutal.
It could be really easy.
Who knows?
Where the harpoon gone?
Yeah, yeah, I'm turning around.
40,000 yen a pop is cash money.
It's so true.
These guys do scare me, though.
Dang it.
Oh, they're all coming.
Do you see them?
Holy cow, there's three of them.
There's sea cows.
Wait, I think I'm getting attacked.
I think I'm getting ambushed.
I think I need to go I think I I think we'll just grab one
for now Take you in my arms YouTube don't get mad at me.
It's art
Coward did you see how many there were?
Did you see how many there were?
You can see a little bit of nip I'll move over I'll show
you.
If I hold it, wait.
Wow, what is this model that they got?
For real though.
Oh, that's my hat.
That's my hat.
Look at this!
It's so detailed!
I think I could see everything.
YouTube, don't get mad at me.
It's awesome.
Art.
Artistic nudity.
And it's also a fish.
Aisha.
If we got like two more, we would be able to get the gun.
Crazy.
Got that areola.
Yes, she do.
All right.
Fuel up.
Off we go to the piranha.
this guy yeah why did this guy mark himself on the map and
then leave I'm confused
worker would be so happy what's
in here mazla all
right let's get some jellyfish some jelly jelly let's get
Some jelly jellies.
And so we can get...
They must not be so difficult to get if we have to get 20 of
them.
I forgot it was 20 of them.
That's so many.
Oops.
How could you miss?
This guy doesn't even move.
Peanut butter jelly time.
My light scared me.
Peanut butter jelly top Peanut butter jelly top Peanut
butter jelly Peanut butter jelly Peanut butter jelly And a
baseball bat I have very vivid memories Of like summer camp
And learning that song Okay you have no mouth Oh yes you do
It's stuck in there Never mind Sorry Alright How do I find
How does one find Oh, they would be in red, no?
So, like...
Let's just go in here or something.
Did I lose one?
Oh, oh, they're here!
Oh, they're going over there!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh,
they come in, like, hordes.
Wait, why are you chomping?
Beto, this!
How many do I have?
Is that what they mean by the bait?
I think one fell out because I saw, like, some bait...
Oh, he's still chomp-chompin.
I saw some bait, like, that looked like it fell into the
water.
Okay.
This is...
It's awkward, but it's doable.
Yeah, they went for it.
They went crazy.
So funny.
Okay, six.
Ah, 20.
Oof.
I'm gonna try this area again, though.
It seems not bad.
It seems they'll cut.
Oh, I see.
I see.
It's on the radar.
Oh no, don't look at me.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't chomp, chomp on me.
Nice.
Still got him.
I'm like, it looks like I'm dropping multiple, but I don't
think I am.
Have we found the one piece before Luffy and become queen of
the pirate Madoes?
Is that, is that one of, I'm, is that one of my goals?
Let's pull up right there.
Place it in my fish.
All right, we're officially, oh, we're halfway there.
Oh, do I want to go get more?
Yes, just in case.
I think I will.
Hold on, I'm going to get some jellies for cash.
money I'm gonna get some jellies for cash money and also
because I feel if they attack me I will survive but I might
run out of I might run out of gas or rather I won't have
enough gas to get back to the gas station so we'll do that I
think I lost my bait again.
It rolls out so quickly.
It rolls out so fast.
My bait fell off.
What happens if you run out of gas?
You lose...
It only happened to me in the demo.
Actually, the main game is so much more forgiving than how
the demo worked.
But if you run out, you, if anything that you had on your
boat, you lose.
Um, and, uh, I think you just teleported back here.
I'm pretty sure.
All right, baby!
There it is.
I lost!
We
saved the money.
We saved the money.
Shop.
it's kind of funny because you like look at this guy and
you're just like is he a scary fish man or is he chilla's
chilla chilla's art model it could very be one it could be
both it could be anything is it jank of game or real scary
fish man i'm so late omg it's okay thanks for dropping by at
all appreciate it i mean to be fair this was a gorilla
stream and it was in the middle of it was outside of my
normal streaming hours on a weekday so it's all good is my
boat sinking no i have a very sturdy boat very sturdy and uh
yeah I wonder if the, um...
If the gun would be good here.
Gorilla stream.
Unga bunga!
I thought this was a game about fish.
What are you talking about?
We're literally in the jungles of sunken Tokyo.
Okay.
They're coming.
They're coming!
Yes.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, they're chomping.
They're chomping, chomping.
Uh-oh, chomping time!
Where'd he go?
Oh, I'm still holding him.
I missed the last guy.
That's too bad.
The jungles of Japan.
The concrete jungles.
It's a concrete jungle.
Oh, we're so close.
How?
Oh, they're 10,000.
Okay.
Just two more!
Yahoo!
Woo!
Shut up!
Wait a second, I just realized this too!
That character is Obakenu!
These are Obakenu plushies.
Oh, they're so cute!
little ghosts like they have different like i have that
literally i have this angel guy on my desk like at this very
moment oh my god i love obakinu what that's so awesome i
just realized i just noticed it all the real ads are in here
what's going on all right all we have to do is grab two hi i
mean though i hope you're doing well you too brandon they're
coming and oops, I missed I can grab two at once I can grab
none at once I can grab two at once
now we got extra income
now Chela's art is mainstream our little indie developers
hello?
oh I need to grab the fish to place a fish um yeah we'll
talk to him not bad let's see how long you last thank you oh
i missed i almost missed a shell
whoa let's go sell these and then we end game question board
Maybe?
Oh, I thought I lost all of my fish.
I was about to be like, no freaking way.
I know I'm like zooming through here, but come on.
I want the harpoon gun.
I want the harpoon.
I don't know if I need the harpoon gun.
But I want the harpoon gun.
I'm going a little bit slower.
No eyes.
No hands.
Okay, I think they're all right.
I think they're okay.
They're okay.
Do piranhas taste good?
How do they taste?
I don't know.
Has anyone eaten piranhas before?
Anybody with some knowledge?
Are you going to have a little break and dinner next stream
if I have time I will try if I have time wait oh oh I didn't
mean to sorry my bad I have a butterfingers oh the gun
we got the gun we got the
gun watch this be completely useless now that'd be so funny?
That would be so funny.
If I don't need it at all.
Um, yeah.
I mean, I can't upgrade anything else anyway.
Oh wait, do I have enough money to refuel?
Oh shoot, I just realized.
Oh yeah, we're totally good.
Okay, let's go to the tower.
What the heck is wrong with you guys?
You guys crave more blood than me, I think.
Let's blow up that shark!
I hope it's not like a defense thing where it's like, while
I'm setting this up, you...
You...
Hello?
You defend me.
Oh!
You found all four parts!
Thank you!
This should let us take the shark down.
That shark looks tough.
It's not normal.
even close.
Then again, neither are we.
Yeah, we're the special fish.
Apparently, there's a person inside that shark's mouth.
Wait, oh, we're aiming.
Okay, I thought we were trying to not aim for the person in
their mouth, but we do want the person in their mouth.
Hitting the shark itself doesn't seem to do anything.
We've got what we need.
Let's finish this.
I left the weapon on the top of the tower so you can use it
right away.
I wish you the best of luck.
Don't forget to take what the shark is carrying.
Oh, I have to do the work also?
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, now we get to climb it.
I hope nobody has a fear of heights.
What a thrill.
With darkness and silence through the night.
I'm searching and I'll melt into you.
What a fi- Oh, oh my god, it's ready.
Oh my god, it's ready.
Oh.
Maybe I shot it out of the sky, and now I do have to aim.
You know what I mean?
Maybe I do have to fight it still.
That's probably what it is, is now he's swimming around.
It's a real a while.
Can I just jump?
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, okay, okay.
Don't forget to collect what he's saving.
Or what he's...
No, I'm saving.
Sorry, wait.
Collect what he's holding.
That makes sense, I think.
Where is he?
Maybe I should have upgraded my sonar.
He's gone already.
He seems really fast.
The hunt begins.
Oh!
Oh, no,
not...
I don't even think it...
Oh, it is picking up those guys.
Oh.
No, not you!
Supreme, so you're by!
Wait a second.
There's another thing over here.
You see it?
Also, there's like mountains.
Another gate.
Oh, I don't like- wait!
It's another gas station.
Wait, I- Where am I?
Oh no, I'm at the other side.
What the?
Oh look at that!
That's handy.
Oh, I've been going all the way back to the other side for
no reason!
This has been here the whole time!
I'm gonna set it as a marker so we don't forget about it.
But to be fair, I was going back and selling things too,
so...
Oh gosh, this fight, what am I, am I fighting the end?
Like, what, what is this?
It's so slow.
I should have upgraded my sonar.
Could he be anywhere?
Are we saying anywhere, anywhere in this whole city?
He's not gonna come after me at all?
Oh!
Where's the person in your mouth?
Hello?
Wait, I can't move.
Turn around, please.
Open wide.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is so stinky.
I don't know the timing.
Oh,
he's holding me hostage again.
Oh, thank you.
Maybe for me there.
Guys, I'm confused.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't know he was lunging twice.
Oh, I'm stuck on top of him.
Please, can I, like, see your mouth or something?
Oh.
Oh, I'm stuck again.
He is making it so I can't move.
Okay, where is he coming from?
I'm gonna go get more gas.
Well, at least we have the gun, so we should do more damage,
right?
Which is the idea.
Hopefully he stays there.
Don't go anywhere, Shark!
I'm coming back for you!
It was a tactical retreat!
I don't need to save.
I didn't do any damage to him.
I saved right before we started the fight, actually.
Are you still around here?
Hello?
Please say yes.
Oh, yes, yes, yes, good, good.
I don't know what an opening...
Ah!
Oh, like that!
Okay, okay.
Oh my god.
Wait, what's happening to my boat?
Oh my god, I'm stuck on him again.
Oh, I'm stuck again.
I can't move.
Oh, I got him, though.
Nice.
Oh, my gosh.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, now we're talking business.
Yeah, baby.
Are you gonna lift up your mouth?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, shoot.
No, no, please.
Hold.
Hold!
Hold for me!
This is kind of goofy.
Oh, here we go.
I'm gonna try again and get him.
Ah, I got him!
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Yes, yes, yes.
And now you open your mouth?
Now you open your mouth?
Open your mouth for me?
Show me your little human body?
Yeah!
We're so close!
Say ah!
We heard the dentist?
Oh, I'm stuck again.
This might be the last hit, actually, if I can get it.
Ah!
I jinxed myself.
Where'd he go?
Wait, where'd he go?
No!
Oh, okay.
That would have been so epic.
Okay.
Where is he?
Oh no!
My thing ran out.
And...
Are you flying?
Oh, I attached it.
Oh, hello!
Oh, he's bowing.
Yes, do you accept this dance, my lady?
Place three tablet shards into Shrine Door near First
Island.
How much is this guy going to sell for?
This guy who's been terrorizing the city, apparently.
Do I need to talk to you?
She's gone.
he looks like uh what's his name from mouth washing oh save
good idea thank you what if we just not sell him what if we
take him along for the ride for with us for eternity curly
yeah he looks like curly
one million yen you really need a bigger boat or do you just
need to give me Guys?
Guys?
Oh.
Is everything okay?
Are we all right?
That froze my entire computer.
Everything just froze just now.
We're back?
Okay.
That was scary.
Alright, Curly.
It's time for us to say goodbye.
Oh, meet again.
Don't know where.
But I know we'll meet again.
A sunny day.
Caught a giant shark.
No way, you took that shark down!
Poor bastard.
Maybe this really was the better ending for him.
So you've gathered all three sharks.
That means the tablet is complete.
I don't know whether to worry or feel relieved.
Where it points should be an island.
You'll have to go alone from here.
Go on if it's truly what you want.
How much does he sell for though?
It really is 1 million!
That would have been an unfortunate time for the stream to
crash.
But at least I just saved, right?
Holy cow, imagine.
1 million.
Do we save him?
I mean, do we sell him or do we bring him along with us?
I kind of like him as like my my you know little buddy on
the back of my boat I don't know if I fast travel with him
though you know if I fast travel will I lose it and then
lose out on the million
hold on we're saving and we're going somewhere else
oh Let's go!
Let's go!
Our little buddy.
He's so huge.
He's so big!
Alright.
I know I'm half-fuel, but it's right here anyway, so why
not?
Where'd the girl go?
Insert.
Why is it making us out?
Oh.
Follow the light ahead.
More bells!
Oh, come on, man.
Is it that one that I saw?
I think so.
Yeah.
Is that one that I saw?
It is.
We gotta go back.
What's happening?
Oh, I think it...
Was it the bells?
Oh!
I have a bell on my...
Oh.
I have a bell on my thing now!
Wait, what the hell?
It's not back.
heavy.
It's not back heavy at all.
It's not.
I promise.
Oh, let's refuel first.
My bad.
Actually, we can fast travel to that first area.
We can fast travel.
To ominous city back.
Yes, I knew it.
I knew it.
Are we all here?
Okay.
All right.
Team's all here.
Oh, sorry.
I meant to press this.
and get this off my screen.
There we go.
Okay.
The gang's all here.
Okay, save.
Let's go, baby!
Oh.
What did I say?
It looks like you're ready to go from here.
Thanks for making it this far.
I can finally see him again.
I'll get on your boat with you.
Iko.
Just a little more.
I'm so glad I met you.
Iko!
mind my buddy.
You like the decorations?
So what is this now?
What does this mean?
I don't even have the right guys.
I have to sell him.
I don't have the right speed level.
I think I have to sell him.
So only yellow bell, no orple bell.
Maybe we can catch some jellyfish.
Touch some jellyfish.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll catch some jellyfish.
I don't think it was so expensive for the next upgrade.
Oh, my God.
Don't mind me.
Also, don't mind the light.
Don't mind your shadows.
I don't like the way this gun sounds.
It's really loud and hurts my ears.
Wait a second.
I have an idea.
Was it 400k?
These guys only give me...
Oops.
Not a lot.
400k?
Oh, we're so...
Oh, no.
Uh...
Maybe we can get a mermaid.
That's 40 mermaids!
No, it's not.
That's like 10 mermaids, right?
yeah guys i think i have to sell him because i do have
another stream in about an hour i think it's time to sell
our boy
i think i have to sell him
i'm sorry i should have never bought the good oh
Oh, I'll meet again.
No, nowhere.
Bye.
Oh.
It's just a bot.
I can't.
I don't want to part with him.
He looks so good on the back of my boat.
Oh, wait, I forgot the reason I came here.
I can't even afford the second speed.
Sheesh.
Alright.
Oh, wow, you won't let me...
Fine, I'll play your games.
Wait, I am in the front.
Why won't you let me teleport to the back?
There's a will, there's a way.
Gone but not forgotten.
My boat looks so empty.
now!
Oh, I'm at the back, that's right.
Alright, here we go!
Oh wait, let me also refuel.
We will always remember.
Remember how he was on my bow and it was so cute.
Okay, so no purple, but yes... I don't even know where I'm
going to though.
I don't know if I'm doing this right or not.
Am I doing this right?
Oh!
My bell disappeared!
Oh, I can't see anything!
Oh!
Did we die?
What?!
No way!
Oh, I didn't know it had a limited time use.
Okay, well...
Now we know.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I wish I could boost it.
I really wish I could boost.
Okay, that's all I got.
I think of it though.
Wait, I think it's here.
Ah, please!
No, please!
Did I make it?
I think I made it?
Oh my god, we just barely made it.
Whoa, that was so lucky.
Oh, nice.
Wow!
We made it!
Dad!
Thank goodness I finally found you.
They brought me all the way here.
You made it all the way here, and Myuna came with you too?
I am the one who sees through all things.
It was I who cast the curse upon this world.
I pride myself on being something close to a guard.
I think this is the... No, this is not the fish from the...
Cover art.
Great whale voice.
Thank you.
And yet even I was swallowed by anger.
The endless lament echoing from the sea's depths.
The cries of lives trampled by humans.
I listened to it all and learned what humans foolish, what
human foolishness truly was.
I believed I could not leave humans as they were.
But if humans and fish traded places, peace would come.
It seems building a world is difficult for fish with so
little reason.
Hi, I'm Fish, and yesterday I had memory for five seconds,
and today I have memory for five years.
I don't even know how to twiddle my thumbs.
Even so, you alone became a true human.
Dad, listen.
What I saw out there was awful.
Those fish that look like people, they only have the worst
parts of humans, And they kept that thing fish have,
cannibalism.
The worst things that, the worst thing that fish have is
It turned into something truly messed up.
It tried to fix this world on your own and it nearly killed
you.
I don't blame you.
I tried my best, I tried to tell everyone in my own way, but
no one listened.
They simply do not have the capacity to do so.
She said the word!
It always comes back to get him.
How do you keep doing this, Vito?
I don't know.
Humans really are selfish, huh?
And you.
Humans hurt you too.
So I get why you thought you had no choice.
It's horrible.
The old world was still better than this.
That's why I think we should put everything back.
That doesn't have much time.
We'll handle what happens to this world from here.
You don't have to push yourself anymore.
I think we should break the curse, make fish and humans go
back to how they were.
But in the end, it's my decision.
Truly a mythos dream.
At least it's not humans eating humans, it's just fish
cannibalism, okay?
Because I believe you're the one who should take the helm of
this world.
Me?
No matter what happens, I'll accept it.
And, oh, and there it is, the omnipotent whale.
Oh, hello.
So you made it to the end.
Oh, why does he look so freaky, though?
I had the hunch you'd be the one to bring me here.
Right, I wasn't, I was looking for that whale too, wasn't I?
And hey, thanks for catching so many humans for me.
I don't even remember why anymore, but I used to hate
humans.
But now, I don't know, it feels, it started to feel like it
doesn't matter.
Hate doesn't do anything.
The world doesn't get better.
True.
I still want to make this world better though.
But I have a fish at the end of the day, aren't I?
I try to think and nothing comes.
So I started an organization.
I think that involves a lot of thinking, no?
There's still so much I want to learn, so much I want to do.
I don't want to turn back into a fish like this.
As you can see, the time is coming to an end.
I know you've seen this world with your own eyes.
And from what I've felt, you seem to have the ability to
think.
Humans are something even I, a whale, can't fully
understand.
So now I want your answer.
And I want to entrust this world to you.
Were the humans you met evil itself?
Wait, what?
If I say...
Wait, the humans, like the fish humans that I met?
If I say no...
I think they were just fish.
I think they were fish.
That's one thing that, like, is pretty bad that humans do.
Is they humanize animals.
Like, they give too many...
They give animals, like, human characteristics, you know?
Um...
Hmm.
So, if I say yes, will it...
So, if I say yes, does it go to her side?
If I say no, it sticks with...
The guy.
She's so cute, though.
Anthropomorphous maxing.
So true.
You murdered that poor fish that was just enjoying his boat.
You were the evil, Minto.
I'm a former human, so maybe.
She's a human and not evil.
So no.
Oh, that's true.
So, yeah, I was going to say no anyway, though.
No.
Is there a correct way to be human?
Everybody comes in their own shape and size.
No.
Must humans be perfect?
Is something fails once?
Is it never allowed to try again?
No.
Is it already too late to atone for my mistake?
Oh.
No.
Should the curse be reversed?
Yes?
Are you sure?
Is it because you heard me say yes, question mark?
Uh, yes.
If that is what you say, then so be it.
I'm sorry.
Go back to being a fish.
You cost me a lot of money.
I also want to be a fish and not have to think about money.
Oh, get ending A!
Am I a fish?
Oh,
no, the people...
Wait, are they drowned?
Oh, gosh.
Why do they look like that?
Wait, they're not drowned, are they?
Just swim!
You turned back human, swim!
Uh-oh.
Did I kill everybody?
Wait, how was this the bad ending?
I'm sorry, but reversing the curse is...
That's the bad ending.
That's me.
The one that's just lying there really peacefully.
Just straight lying.
I kind of want to try for the second ending.
Seems like the whale forgot some important details with
reversing the curve.
Look on the right side, the ocean is full of food now.
Oh, did I make the right choice?
That's a free question game.
Oh, we get to do it again!
Oh, awesome.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, nice.
The game is judging me for real.
Alright, let's skip all of there.
Skip, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip.
Skip, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip.
They give me a second chance!
I think, though...
Okay, I think these are all still right though.
No, no, no, no, no, should the curse be reversed?
No!
Then tell me, what is a human?
How can this world be made better?
To coexist.
Give once fish humans the power to think.
I feared the day you would speak that answer aloud ironic
isn't it for them to live together i must make them more
human this is like deep no i refuse to accept that for so
long that if but if that if that is your answer very well
the brain blast your wish shall be granted
I feel like endings for some of these games are kind of like
but this is
oh with their little safe accord still it's so cute
oh oh I like the ones that are like spawning out of nowhere
it's kind of freaking does that mean more humans are being
born or like what's going on look there's so more They're
all, they're just fish now.
Like, they don't look like freaky human fish.
They're just fish fish.
Except that guy.
Holy cow.
Oh, oh, umibazu!
Why is this so cute?
Oh, wait, he didn't die!
There's schools!
Dongi.
Don't eat fish and don't eat people.
Who the hell is that?
I don't remember that guy in my class.
Wow!
There's like so many people.
There's children.
Wait, did we teach that to them too?
Look at that girl's spin!
Wait!
Artuna!
Oh, this is so cute!
He's like a dog!
He's like that dancing dog meme!
You know what I'm talking about?
Oh, my baby!
My baby Tuna!
The
water is still messed up there.
The water is still messed up in that one spot.
Oh, there was a sponsor.
Oh, this guy.
I like this one so much.
This is so fun.
Fish or lovers, not food, noted.
You will, the fish.
That guy, he was on his boat again.
Him, like, popping in and out is so funny.
Oh, whoa!
He's zooming.
The music's so cute, too.
Oh, oh, yeah, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh.
Oh, yeah, there's Zozo.
Village Vanguard.
Wow, their way.
They actually were in here.
That's crazy.
I wonder who I was, you know?
I
guess this means your wisdom from earlier can no longer
apply unless you're, like, catching criminal fish only.
No, they're their own types of humans.
Chilla got sponsors now.
Maybe that's why the game, like, is longer.
The appearance of a higher budget.
Good work, Mito!
Thank you!
Who's that?
Crying up tall.
Who is that?
I actually like this one so much, though.
That was really fun.
Thank you, guys.
I would stick around for longer, but I have another stream
in an hour, so...
Yay!
We finished Umigari!
Yuppie!
Yuppie, yuppie!
Hot dog.
Hot dog!
Dried princess, thank you!
Are fish humans?
Are humans fish?
Why does Minto play games with cannibalism?
This game has so many questions.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you!
I'm going to set the redirect to my next stream.
Where we will be finishing...
Oops, that's not what I meant to do.
We will be finishing contradiction!
And I will be there in one hour!
And if you're watching the VOD, you should also go watch
contradiction.
the part two if you haven't watched it yet so yeah thank you
so much everybody thank you thank you thank you I'll see you
when I see you next bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye
pick me thank you bye-bye probably one of Chela's best games
to date I know right I'm like so I feel good I feel good
that was such a feel good ending bye-bye